[Música]
é eu vim aqui pra falar sobre uma guerra
uma guerra que começou em 2011 e que me
obrigou a obrigou a minha família sair
do nosso país sem saber se onde nós
vamos voltar ou não à guerra da síria
que completou 18 anos dentro de um
contexto da primavera árabe que começou
com conflitos contra o governo de bashar
lançado o governo dela são de família já
está no poder há mais de 40 anos em 2012
esse conflito 67 ficaram entre diversos
grupos armados é pior a chorar ainda
mais comentada do estado islâmico no
país
o estado islâmico que aproveitou a
fragilidade do país a conquistar
territórios é recrutar soldados também é
pra minha família trégua veio em 2014
quando decidimos ir embora do país
mas antes disso tínhamos uma vida
tranquila
meu pai é engenheiro civil era dono de
uma empresa de elevador é minha mãe
o economista era dona de uma agência de
viagens
minhas irmãs toda a medicina e economia
já são formadas
eu nasci na época uma das é uma das
cidades mais antigas do mundo é uma das
maiores da cena que mais de 5 milhões de
habitantes
era uma cidade super tranquila eu podia
ficar na rua com meus amigos até muito
tangível muitas horas de tangi sentir
medo de violência ou sentir medo de ser
assaltado mas infelizmente essa
realidade mudou em 2012 quando a
população queria mais liberdade é
protestava contra a ditadura mas o
exército reagiu com violência é só
deixar as pessoas ficaram mais
revoltadas ainda os os protestos que
poderiam ser resolvidos pacificamente
foram espalhadas pelas cidades chegando
na minha cidade a limpo que ficou
dividido entre dois lados um lado com e
que ficou com uma força do exército a
favor do governo é outro lado que ficam
com uma população armada
contra o governo onde eu morava no lado
do governo era que sempre tem mais
afetado é por causa de falta dos
materiais principal principais para
sobreviver nesse período eu estava
prestando vestibular pra conseguir
entrar na faculdade de engenharia
elétrica na universidade de aleppo
foi um dos dias antes das provas do
vestibular que comecei a ouvir os
barulhos de bombas e tiros na minha
cidade e depois destes dias ficam esses
barulhos uma coisa tranqüila é uma coisa
normal é tipo uma coisa no seu dia a dia
tentamos sobreviver mais que um ano
nessa situação muitos dias sem água
muitos dias sem energia elétrica há
muitos dias em gás sem comida e sem
combustível sem dizer e dizer que era
uma coisa muito importante pra fazer
aquecimento em casa
época por que não inverno a temperatura
chega a ser menos cinco granadas em pô
eu não tinha esse é sempre materiais é
por causa de falta de trabalho em falta
de dinheiro meus pais decidiram se mudar
para uma outra cidade que se chama ataca
a cidade onde o presidente nessa nação
era uma cidade é um pouco mais tranquila
porque senão vai querer levar algumas
coisas de trabalho dele de ficar ou não
sobreviver sobreviver no estoque dele de
tentar vender nessa cidade
a minha mãe foi acompanhar ele é o mesmo
azar mas ficamos naquela época por causa
dos estudos
havia muitos momentos que nós não
conseguia não conseguimos contato com
ele por causa de falta de sinal é por
causa de falta da internet em casa é nós
não tínhamos notícia deles nem ele tinha
notícia de nós é cada um de um mês mais
ou menos ele não conseguir vou ele
voltar à vontade nos revela é pó porque
era super de festeiro voltar por causa
de caminho que era um caminho
alternativo a alternativa porque o
governo teve que fecha a fechar o
caminho principal policiais demoraram
muito tempo pra ele voltar pra voltar
agora dia
de janeiro de 2013 era uma terça-feira
era um dia nacional dos exames nas
faculdades do país
todos os estudantes universitários seria
fazer um exame nesse dia foi acompanhar
dois amigos meus querer fazer esse exame
energia
depois de uma hora mais ou menos a gente
falar na faculdade de arquitetura
depois de uma hora mais ou menos é uma
amiga não acabou aprovada e saiu e pediu
para a gente resolver algumas coisas
dele no bairro do lado da faculdade
nós fomos embora e depois mais ou menos
uns 15 a 20 minutos
ouvimos um barulho de bomba e uma fumaça
saídas e bebemos um dos carros de
resgate carregando pessoas mortas e
feridas
assim muitas pessoas começarem a ser ele
foi quando nós entendemos o que havia
acontecido que foi uma bomba lançada bem
onde a gente estava 20 minutos atrás na
faculdade de arquitetura é essa
faculdade que fica desse jeito desse
jeito depois da de s
10 e ataca no real mais que 80 pessoas
neste ataque
ele foi ferido mais de 190 pessoas
feridas
eu tenho um amigo meu também que está
aquele amigo que estava fazendo a prova
dentro da faculdade ela sobreviveu e
conseguiu ligar as da gente falar por
favor leiam meus pais às vezes há males
que eu estou vivo estou bem não
aconteceu nada comigo mas infelizmente
depois de algumas horas descobrimos que
o pai dele que estava esperando dele
fora da faculdade e foi atendido e foi
morta é a mãe dele que trabalhava na
faculdade do lado também foi atendido e
ficou de cadeiras de rodas
eu acho que alguns de vocês já deve ter
visto alguma notícia desse de seu ataque
nos jornais brasileiras que apareceu
aqui no brasil é depois desse ataque dos
meus pés desse dinheiro na saia do país
meu pai tem no flamengo será que mora há
muito tempo no brasil
meu pai conseguiu contato dele e
conversou com ele apenas
a situação é perguntou ele a algumas
coisas básicas sobre o brasil é
perguntou uma das coisas que nem a
pergunta era como era viver em liberdade
e 77 tinha algum tipo de preconceito
contra o hiv o muçulmano
o amigo dele falou que não acreditava
todo mundo todo mundo livro que ele e no
que ele acredita realmente gostamos da
idéia o dinheiro para brasil e chegamos
no brasil um dia 15 de abril em 2014 e
chegamos em campinas
sem saber falar nada de português além
de algumas palavras que a gente aprendeu
pela internet igual obrigado alguns
números sem saber o que é o quê qué
brasil o que vamos fazer no brasil sem
saber nada sobre o brasil
além de alguns jogadores de futebol
famosos gol neymar pelé começou em 2014
mesmo quando a gente chegou eu comecei a
trabalhar algumas coisas e foi mais pra
aprender a língua mais rápido possível
é mais para conhecer pessoas novas
amigas que ter amigos brasileiros
eu trabalhei a a ao longo de seis meses
até meus pais conseguiram abrir um
restaurante em campinas chama história
de castela abrir essa restaurante
nesse mesmo ano eu comecei o processo
seletivo para fazer a transferência de
enquanto continuarmos todos aqui na
unicamp recebeu um homem já na área
janeiro de 2015 que eu tenho que fazer
um exame de transferência já conseguir
começar antes de todos
só que tenho que fazer é sentar me
receber era de 2015
como não teve muito tempo para me
preparar e não estava muito ruim em
português não conseguiu passar pela
primeira vez mais o coordenador do curso
me falou que eu tenho outros outra
chance pra conseguir no segundo semestre
de 2015
daí eu comecei a estudar sozinho contra
a conhecer pessoas da unicamp que são as
alunos informados mestrado de física
engenharia química particular
ajudar muito muito pra pensar nestas
exames é realmente conseguir passar no
segundo semestre de 2015
o congresso oficialmente na unicamp em
agosto de 2015
nós na verdade é praticamente minha vida
acadêmica começou em 2016 quando eu
comecei a conhecer pessoas novas
comecei a fazer matérias em outros como
a turma e conhecer eu comecei a sair com
meus amigos final de semana a ir para
festas
isso é uma falta na festa de quatro
matérias quem fez aquele semestre com o
português ruim conseguir passar em duas
matérias e foi muito bem assim fiquei
muito feliz
levo na verdade um tempo pra cá eu
adaptar com uma metodologia da faculdade
é da terra como é as aulas na unicamp a
data como a o idioma português foi
melhorando cada um semestre mais mas até
semestre passado que eu cursei essas
matérias é conseguir passar em todas
essas matérias e agora semestre
e agora também neste semestre
estou tentando fazer mais três plantas
estão fazendo seis matérias estou
tentando me esforçar para conseguir
passar de novo nos dias que não têm
aulas de manhã eu ajudo meus pais no
restaurante chinês tem normalmente no
restaurante os brasileiros costumam
sempre ele gera comida era recomenda
séria é sempre costuma fazer umas
perguntas parecidas igual como era a sua
vida na síria estão acostumados aqui no
brasil como esta ainda na faculdade
tá tudo certo aqui com vocês sempre
fazer essas mesmas perguntas normalmente
sempre com ele costuma eleger o
português saiu não sei porquê mas ele
sempre fala que sou português também
acho que vocês brasileiros já ouvi muito
notícias sobre a síria só que na verdade
vocês não entendo muito bem o que está
acontecendo de verdade lá é uma guerra
complexa ânsia de diversos grupos
armados
a briga entre diversas grupos
terroristas grupos armados exército
população civil
apesar de ser um confronto antena e
civil
mas muitos países estrangeiros igual
estados unidos canadá turquia e israel
sem envolver diretamente ou
indiretamente nesse confronto é uma
guerra complexa
nossa eu quem mais sofre na verdade
estão os civis
hoje há as mulheres as crianças
um exemplo esta foto foto desse menino
que apareceram nas mídias a que apareceu
nas médias em 2016
a menina era na ambulância estava na
ambulância depois do ataque na minha
cidade na alepa
ele tem apenas quatro anos depois do da
síria a gente saiu da ser a guerra
continua ainda vai continuar aparecendo
essas dessas faltas nas medianas
infelizmente depois disso depois desta
foto apareceu
muitos brasileiros alguns que eu
conhecia alguns que eu nem conhecia nem
enviar mensagens pelo pela rede social
perguntando sobre esse menino é falando
esse time pra cá apesar de eu não
conhecer ele
eles começaram a falar trás ele pra cá a
gente vai adotar ele
nós vamos cuidar bem deles só por favor
3 ele pra cá tipo não saber o que fazer
nós sabemos que na verdade os
brasileiros querem ajudar de alguma
forma é ninguém me contou sobre a guerra
eu vivi essa guerra sente medo e pg
conhecidas bm universidade sem destruir
a minha cidade será atacada mas graças a
deus teve a sorte tive a sorte de
sobreviver de recomeçar minha vida que
os brasileiros são a tratam bem os
estrangeiros os brasileiros são legais
ele estreia ele esteja seca mais legais
ainda quando eu falo que eu sou da síria
e assim fica muito mais legal 80 me
ajudar o máximo que eles conseguem hoje
eu estou numa dada uma universidade das
melhor de da américa latina o melhor do
mundo
eu tenho amigos brasileiros eu tenho eu
falo português
eu tenho uma namorada brasileira é minha
família toda trabalha é o mestre
importante de tudo o que eu falei até
agora que eu vejo no país que não sabe o
que é ganhar chocando obrigado
[Aplausos]